hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
sieg vorstellung ihr habt gestern wieder
die benötigte anzahl an daumen hoch
geschafft und zwar 2000 waren es glaube
ich wenn ihr jetzt bei diesem video 2250
oder sagen wir mal 2500 like sowie ihr
beim ersten video ab gegangen seid das
war unglaublich das sind schon
mittlerweile glaube ich 9000 oder so
wenn ihr jetzt dieses video 2500 like
schafft dann kommt morgen wieder eine
sieht vorstellung noch mal ganz kurz zu
der serie viele leute meinten jetzt
sieht man viele leute mir hey bisher for
like geil
mehr ich nutze nur diese funktion damit
ihr quasi selbst bestimmen können ob ihr
tägliches verstellung wollt oder nicht
weil wenn irgendwann die leute keinen
bock mehr haben auf sieht vorstellungen
die dann von mir täglich kommen dann
könnte er das einfach drunter schreiben
und sagen nee ich gebe es keinen daumen
hoch daumen runter weil ich das nicht
möchte ist natürlich auch alles legitim
also ihr dürft quasi selbst entscheiden
ich könnte auch einfach sagen ja ihr
könnt mal versuchen 1000 kommentare
hinzukriegen mit dem kommentar sieht
aber das ist ja egal oder den daumen
hoch kann es einfach viel besser sehen
deswegen einfach 2500 und ab morgen
wieder eine zielvorstellung wenn nicht
dann halt nicht
ich muss selbst gucken wir das
durchziehen kann also hier haben wir
diesmal einen neuen zieht den ich sehr
geil finde bei den letzten beiden sie
zwar einige meckern
der cee'd ist der hier 55 96 65 31 70 79
82 2 4 3 2 2 steht doch immer unten in
der beschreibung übrigens hab ich dir
schreiben jetzt ein bisschen modifiziert
und unten auch alle playlist reingepackt
also ein paar wohl dann auch wiederum
stöbern können zum beispiel real life
sachen epic komplett mit komme und so
was alles steht alles nicht mittlerweile
und in der beschreibung drin also das
ist auf jeden fall der sieht wenn ihr da
einfach mal in die beschreibung gucken
könnte das wäre schon cool dann seid ihr
immer auf dem neuesten stand sind
netzwerke drin und so naja also wissen
relativ genau hier ich bin nicht genau
hier glaube ich dass es bond immer so
hier sind ein paar sehen auch dieses
stipendium sage ich mal finde ich
eigentlich ist das geilste was es gibt
weil ich finde ich mag die gras farbe
und ich finds auch cool dass man hier so
ein bisschen einfach bauen kann direkt
hier neben ist ein npc dorf mpc doch
relativ langweilig ein paar komische
konstruktion sind natürlich auch wieder
am start ist auch typisch
ich finde es langweilig weil hier keine
man es vor allem abseits abseits bayern
hat gerade 40 geworden
schreibt man drunter was von fußball
fanclub ihr seid oder wenn ihr sport
macht was führt was ihr lieblingssport
so ist es wird mich mal interessieren
welche wieder lange bundesregierung
besser vor der weltfussball finde ich
ganz klar danach kommt handball würde
ich sagen ja wir haben ja so einen
brunnen der direkt im weg stehe das auch
sehr cool cars sind meine braut ihr
konntet ihr ganz kurz aus unter männern
moschitz moment sieht man das nicht
gerade da dass man sich also hier ist
das mpc dorf und direkt daneben ist ein
mass rubio mit den ganzen tun die da
vorne gestanden wo standen sie da
standen sie drauf da stand für den
früher genau da stehen kühe die haben
die eigenschaft dass nein das kommt der
minecraft guide im nächsten minecraft
die wende nicht kennt ist auch und in
der beschreibung minecraft facts könnte
auch einfach vorbeikommen
also haben wir direkten mushroom
billionen direkt am start hier seht ihr
das ist unglaublich riesig wer das ende
findet kriegt von mir einen dicken
schmatzer auf den mund nach hin also das
ist nicht so groß allerdings ist hier
bei euch vielleicht kein loch ich habe
das dahin gegraben da ist allerdings nur
eine erdschicht so drüber die könnt ihr
dann hier einfach abtragen
das sind diese koordinaten x20 y ca 60
bzw 62
also von der höhe her und z 360 da könnt
ihr euch einfach noch ein graben dann
könnt ihr einfach runter fliegen ich
habe ich unser kloster in szene gesetzt
hat mich vorbereitet natürlich kann man
hier einfach so lange gehen das ist
alles auch schon so ausgehoben also da
kommt man auf so lange ich hab den
ursachen zu beleuchtung eingesetzt und
dann haben wir hier direkt sondern mein
chef bzw sicher heißt es nochmal meinen
chef heißt es mein chef
ich weiß es nicht übrigens habe ich auch
leute gefragt wie ich diese blöcke
einfach so mitnehmen hier solche leute
solche blöcke ich einfach mit der
mittleren maustaste einfach draufklicken
dann habt ihr direkt im inventar also
seht schon hier haben wir schon mein
chef das ist auf jeden fall ganz cool
ist auch riesig groß also wir sehen was
hier das hat mehrere tausend millionen
abermillionen verschiedene wege hier
auch über mehrere etagen das ist echt
schillig es muss ich ihr nur irgendwie
wieder rauskomme ich mach das jetzt
einfach so was mich durch mal das nicht
durch so
da oben ein keinen moment
ich entschuldige diese unangenehm ich
unangenehmen kalten keine ahnung also
erstmal richtig geil dass wir schon mal
mushroom millionen direkt neben dem mpc
dorf haben und dann habe ich mir noch so
koordinations tp daten gespeichert und
zwar gehen wir zu -7 psion 33 und z 357
dann sind wir hier weil man warte jetzt
wieder im moment ist wieder mit pc
kaufmann ich hab' ich vertraue da genau
da ist
ich möchte natürlich natürlich y 300 2
832 dx 832 y 132 seiten was soll ich mir
hier hinter deportiert und wir sind
direkt bei einem nächsten pc auf das
relativ weit weg vom anderen allerdings
was ich euch jetzt ein wenig relativ
entdeckt ist es mit 200-300 blöcke oder
400 500 oder so also ich habe erstmal
und mpc doch auch keine miene drin
allerdings habe ich hier schon so einen
penis einfach mal hingesetzt
also mein penis leuchtet die weißen wie
das bei euch ist bei meiner leuchtet und
hier sollen so zwei solche löcher da
sondern auch und hier wir gehen
allerdings hier rein und schwimmen dann
hier einen wasserfall runter allerdings
kann man jetzt hier in einem
höhlensystem reingehen also das ist
schon relativ großes höhlensystem seht
ihr den weg die ist ein weg dahin
spaltet sich das nochmal das ist
allerdings nicht das was er zeigen
wollte sondern wir können auch einfach
diesen wasserfall ihr weiter runter
gehen und ihr seht schon heute was sind
das für steine ja ja und zwar sind wir
dann hier direkt in so einem
stronghold genau da kommen wir dann
relativ genau hin und das ist allgemein
sehr cool aussieht so führen anfang also
wir haben jetzt nicht sachen ja wir
haben hier diamanten und die haben wir
gold und hier haben wir noch ganz viele
kondome und alles mögliche nein wir
haben hier wirklich direkten stronghold
npc dorf wo man wirklich mit handeln
kann traden kann
mazlum biome immer was zu fressen also
auf jeden fall ganz schillig von
anfangen so wir gehen jetzt mal wieder
zurück genau hier bei der staat könne
noch daran erinnern wir sind dabei dem
komischen mpc dorf da ist es doch oder
da ja genau wir sind hier gespannt und
freundlich wird euch einfach sagen es
euch gefallen hat 2500 likes morgen
kommt noch eine vorstellung wie es beim
nächsten mal tschüss